it likes to describe itself as the
biggest car brand you've never heard
of now China's byd has overtaken Tesla
as the world's largest seller of
electric
vehicles even if you've never heard of
byd there's a chance you've been in one
of its
[Music]
buses while it's taxi proud the street
stre of some of the world's biggest
cities but buses and taxis aren't the
reason why byd has overtaken Tesla
instead it's a fruit of long-term
strategic thinking on the part of byd
itself and the Chinese
government and is setting China up to be
the dominant Global player in the
transportation of the future electric
vehicles a business that could be worth
$8.8 trillion by the end of a
decade here are the three most important
things that have made byd the king of
EVS the Chinese government has played a
huge role in byd's
Rise we've arguably never seen anything
like this in terms of you know the
amount of support uh that that China has
extended to automakers specifically
pertaining to
EVS Beijing has given an estimated $30
billion of tax exemptions to the
industry since 2010 and may wave a
further 97 billion by
2027 China actually takes a Cara and sck
approach they set mandatory EV output
targets for automakers but they also
offer cheaper loans and cheaper land and
R&D subsidies to all those EV makers and
byd has been a massive beneficiary of
that it still sells most of its electric
vehicles in its home Market but of
course Tesla has also benefited from
Chinese subsidies which is where the
second reason for byd's Rise comes
[Music]
in most of byd's cars are simply a lot
cheaper than Tesla's in fact it sells 10
popular models starting from less than
Tesla's cheapest offering for the model
3 sedan and byd sells a lot more of the
cheaper vehicles in its lineup they have
very cheap models starting from
$10,000 their approach has been
extremely different in the sense that
Elon Musk believed that you had to sort
of start from the high end with a sexy
performance car to get people interested
in electric cars and then work your way
down the price Spectrum byd went at it
from the other end where it was about uh
cheap taxis and buses that needed a heck
of a lot of batteries and really sort of
you know drove down the prices of of the
batteries that they could put into
Passenger cars while the average price
paid for a Tesla is about 45,000 the
average byd sells to roughly half that
that of course raises the question how
can it sell them so
cheaply the secret to that price tag
lies in what is known as vertical
integration our vertical integration
capability give us the flexibility is
the fast response to the market Trend as
well as the better support for brand
developing and customer service that's a
fancy way of saying that they make a lot
of the things that go into their
vehicles themselves car makers usually
buy most components from suppliers such
as Bosch continental and active
Volkswagen for instance only makes 35%
of the parts in its ID3 electric car
Tesla meanwhile makes 68% of the parts
that go into its model 3 made in the US
byd makes 75% of the parts that go into
the seal its Flagship model the most
important factor is that by is the only
auto maker that produces all of its
batteries inhouse that was hugely
important during the pandemic when the
supply chains were just absolutely in a
state of chaos for the industry the fact
that byd was in control of its own
destiny gave them a huge leg up over the
rest of the industry and especially as
it pertains to batteries this is a
company that has been in the battery
space since the
1990s buid actually stands for build
your dreams it started out in 1995 as a
battery company they make rechargeable
batteries for mobile phones and other
electronics products and then the
company got into the auto business in
2003 making its own batteries and other
components helps it reduce a lot of
costs that's attracted some bigname
investors call it the continued byd
promotional Road Show and investor
Warren Buffett brought his buddy Bill
Gates along for the ride here in Beijing
it was fantastic I'm amazed at the
quality of that vehicle Warren Buffett
was one of the biggest early investors
in byd through his holding company
Burkshire Hathaway and the Battery
Technology might also give byd a
technological Edge over some Rivals it
uses lithium iron phosphate which is not
only cheaper than other batteries it's
also packaged a lot more
compactly and chemistry is a core
expertise of founder Wang Chung
Fu he's sort of the anti- Elon Musk Wong
is a chemist by training and an engineer
and an anecdote that one of our
reporters was told was that when he was
told he needed to dress up a bit for an
investor meeting he stopped to buy
shirts just sort of off the street and
so he's far from one of the flashier
Executives uh in the Auto
industry this has all set byd up to be
the biggest player in electric
vehicles the question now is whether it
can become one of the world's biggest
car makers full stop and that means
growing outside of China CH in 21 buid
started to step up its Global expansion
it started to launch more passenger
vehicles across the global markets
including Middle East southeast Asia and
Europe it's still a very new entrance in
global markets the volume contribution
is rising but still
small even so byd inside 3 years has
become one of the top selling EV brands
in markets such as Thailand Brazil and
Australia it's also remains to be seen
whether this company can you know
quickly grow in in some of these newer
markets that it's entering where it
isn't well known it isn't
recognized the two most prominent
challenges in byd's global expansion
will be first uh Regulatory
uncertainties and second brand awareness
the European Union is investigating into
Chinese EV subsidies Chinese automakers
they are exporting more of their EVS
into Europe because those cars are
produced in China so the production
costs are pretty low which allows the
automakers to set their prices in the
Europe uh cheaper than the European
counterparts which has been very
alarming to the European Auto industry
one way around that will be to increase
the amount of local production
definitely localization is one of the
very important strategy of bu this
Europe uh strategy and so we are
considering where evaluation different
location in Europe and where we can
build the cars and apart from buses and
trucks byd isn't in the US the trade
tensions between Beijing and Washington
are keeping byd back and giving them
pause to entering the US market for
years Automotive Experts have predicted
established car making giants like GM
Volkswagen or Toyota would catch up with
Tesla in electric vehicles in hindsight
it probably shouldn't be a surprise that
Chinese rival got there
[Music]
first